and so my name is John gran coming I'm a
programmer for and flair who said
cloudflare okay santa clara we are a
starter a sealian reverse proxies
security service and if you have been to
4chan using to 4chan it's okay to admit
it if you have clicked on the main on
reddit or a cat picture you've actually
gone through clattering lots of it's
about million sites you just come
through outside actually if you've done
any of those things you've been through
to go programs that are right and so we
started using go about two years ago now
i joined calculate two years ago and the
CEO said to me is a mr. projects you
won't be able to work on and choose one
go back to London close personally
outside of a area and build one of them
and embarked back to the station at the
airport up late I'm going to do that one
I'm going to do ego and I didn't tell me
buddy about you go apart every girl it's
in go and and what happened was you know
lucky Lucy do it was kind of play also
drip at that point
but it turned out it works really well
so it's a bit like the talk for my AO I
mean it it just worked stable and now
we've got those bills so actually our
DNS infrastructure is a big ring ago and
it's either the fastest on second
fastest spending on a triple a complete
so it's yo go and it's running on time
right and it's been four chan and you're
juror and a million other websites our
compression technology is written girl
and that's running more time around the
world and loads of stuff ssl
infrastructure all sorts of things so we
have written a ton of stuff and go and
one of this is really big for us is
performance so these go programs are
normal right I know they don't they
don't we get restarted write a business
if to read with machine and are
continuously running at high speed and
they have to be little agency because
one thing sky ourselves is fast fast
website performance so you can't add a
well go to scope
and 60 seconds or whatever you can't do
that and so we have the most absurd
profiling go to we could actually in the
two years which we have worked with it
there were times where we didn't do
things in your own didn't see I had
grafted in openssl crypto functionality
because the native recruiter was too
slow and that caused i think the guys to
actually write ticket to make it faster
because they've been embarrassed so we
gotta stay that out now and infected
everything's down in there to go and we
spent all tournament memory the troubles
we have machines that Clara's cost or
ambitions we are where we have to
control how much memories beings by the
programs and when you're serving a
really large number of pictures of cats
and means is using ordinary so we really
care about that and then there's the
lengthen his legs so you know haloween
Control Agency this the summary is all
of these things have been work to get it
to work well with not a lot of work so
there's actually went everywhere and
this talk when somebody else would come
here and talk about something I thought
I don't little bit about go profiling
and not in like extreme crazy depth
which is the use of ideas of things you
could do go so I shortly I'll press this
funny i wish i was looking after out
tony hoare as a professor and student
and
he say it's all the time and I guess you
know he came from machines where there
wasn't getting what many cycles there
wasn't much memory and yet when he saw
was people doing premature optimization
and amazingly number of people who when
they do optimization of code they'll do
things i go i know i know the frozen
buzz API is slow and i'm like how many
times you call it you know oh you
already quit once on staff where the
hell you optimizing it you have to
measure things it's amazing how people
don't actually like measure and when you
better you discover you know crazy crazy
things they're actually slow and the
real thing about going to optimization
is that and what your actual optimizing
is not cpu time it's part of the time
because you actually opens in a time
right if you spend your time optimizing
at one thing you've wait the expensive
cycles are not CPU cycles right there's
no Moore's Law brainpower it seems like
that's where you go onto my eyes you
have to target the right thing so the
goodness sake measure you measure the
hell out of whatever you're doing we
want you doing optimization ago don't
forget this don't don't be tempted to go
I know this is as you describe radically
we done measurements on things like I
would like I'm sure the compressor so
that's a complicated out
that smell even appear on the list so
all right so some things you can do is
measuring whether you use the shower
time command for orita that doesn't
create useful break if you can isolate
something you can use the built-in time
functionality if you go some to
scripting more later that's down seconds
go to that there is this people of
package i'm the most look back froth
which is the profiling it some time and
there is rather amazing live version of
that when you can attach to a live show
profile against it which is kind of cool
if you have something by we do engine
running for their 100 days you'd like an
opportunity and therefore memory and I
mostly this kind of mostly going to talk
about tiny things in store if the memory
verses PS which is a bit of a black up
and reading or PS can tell you about
what memory if you look at you go so the
reservoir set size is this and revert is
this you know if you can actually read
that figure out dinner we can use your
website and
there's a runtime value if there's a
single witness that festivities inside
inside go that's incredibly useful and
there's a lot of information there and
then you can go heat profile out and
again is live you believe this weather
you can connect to a live profiler which
is pretty cool so I'm going to propose
to be used after you go so what is it
was a white sangria crack code which is
hopefully without drilling normal basis
so I wrote this really rubbish LRU cache
so and then I'm going to put a fire just
to give you an idea so just to run
through the two slides of code I think
you should be there least once down so
there's this cache type which is too
it's going to be a have some capacity
something provide items in the cobalt
and holds this item finger chef Keith
bowser's all straight to this point and
I'm going to really rubbish
implementation for what I'm using is a
map and every item has last time I was
accessed so figure out the other regular
sugar decorate the thing so that's what
it look I'm going to come from it's
going to be really awkward track it'll
give us not hear what the profiler can
do and then this is new caption just you
say I want to capture them hold a
thousand items or whatever and then all
those caches and then there's a couple
of functions oh yeah so if you're
putting something into the cache and
it's full then you have to make some
room bye bye Vic ting something and then
you just stick that I to mix of the is
the map that boredom and because it's
read that implementation you make
sting has to iterate to figure out which
is the oldest my there's no water has a
tree and then please what is the oldest
thing right so so this is rubbish but it
doesn't work and and again something is
pretty trivial rebel like all you have
to do this is fast because they don't to
reorder anything just update the last
time the cells use just go this time it
was used in your return thing you found
so this is a rubbish are you cash and so
then what i did was i I need a lot of
email addresses and luckily people keep
losing their customer databases so many
I wanted something where I want it was
some real data and luckily you can
download wheel yeah other people's real
data service thing what does it consumes
email addresses J policy randomly
generates promise and I just all I'm
doing is looking up and they try to look
forward the tomato and what I wanted was
some sort of random data like agree with
you so I took 10 million other dresses
which I cut off the back of a truck
somewhere and valium for a race all I do
is I try and for each which domain
lookup the dmx in the caption it's not
there get it and put it put it into the
cache and i wrote thing that kept the
last 10,000 in this LRU cache and around
10 million email addresses through it
and it took yeah the bloody long time
one minute 48
rubbish now if I was unable to put that
out by myself I could use the profiler
and such start before a fire out and
then when the program is done because
human females stop it and then it
creates this CPU profiler part which is
really quite a small thing and then you
run this this command and it starts this
come online profile and the profiler has
become online angles has three beautiful
visualizations so the first thing you're
going to discover if you go engines as
they can be the top the top ten and
basically samples and yeah what a
surprise mate space that presumption I
wrote is right up there and also
everything to do with iterating hashes
for excellency hash text and iterating
and cooking memory around so obviously I
mean you know maybe trouble there and
there's a bit of garbage capture
something important or not nothing
nothing really exciting and it turns out
the garbage collection is actually to do
need assuming the file as all these
streams coming and it goes through this
cumulative one which gives you which
rolls it up sync now she sees a little
bit of the call graph so as you can see
al khazim main and it's the most
expensive thing possible as you go down
as the push function of course that's
obvious so that's where you have to make
space with the cash is full and so on so
you can see that in the next item is
iterative now so go to a map is it was
really expensive and the data game gives
you the number of samples that you were
in these different parts of the codes
you can see where you were waiting what
the sampling is done now this is going
to call if you have a reasonable program
like this luckily
before we go person from others now
there's a really nice view in the
profiler which is instead of having top
like that you can type web and it
generates an SVG file giving you this
graph of of execution and so this is
what it looks like at least part of it
so it was the topic there is name and
that squirt out rectangle videos put and
then you can see them to spend more time
on this very space function in fact
we're spending a long time in air a long
time an incinerator a long time this you
can instantly see your answers this is
where I have to do want to work and
how's your program gets more more
effective this is really really help you
can really see and you can actually
narrow down even further I have no
example to learn i'm going to show you
where if there was a part of this truly
interested you you can say to the wait
command start at this point so for
example you could say i want to start
with make space just isolate this trip
so when you have a massive program that
loads of stuff going on it's very
helpful to be able to do that the
numbers here tell you how much time come
samples it was in this particular
function so they were here there is 9000
for samples in here and the subject and
2252 when it was actually in here
naughty morning subtitles so this should
L out
pretty much given the sampling now
that's cool if your program is stupid my
mind that you know 10 dates now for
gather my stuff doesn't terminate it
does terminate its bad and so luckily as
ego is very very slightly very very to
anymore and when he does it's a DevOps
problem so you dislike profiling
diseases this is a very cool feature if
instead of importing runtime people off
you import net HTTP prof it registers a
bunch of gamblers with the default HTTP
server and you do damage your code
something like this which may seem this
not support if you're already running
Ned HTTP in your thingy just sort of
attaches itself like something else
eneos and ads ads these things or ads
these particular boots on and a couple
more and then you can just connect to it
so if you get this program running you
could what you do is you do go to people
off and then the URL and people they sit
there the reason says be patient is
there's a 30 second delay it generally
collects 30 seconds of run running day
10 min it gives you the information so
you can then go and run top or
opportunity or where all these kind of
things so this is exactly same day to
distort before but from a sample inside
writing project so when you find out if
you find that we program if you have
this active and you find that you know
some long run program or something for
me it'll be away there's a catch during
say right start providing that give me
there and if you go into a web browser
and gives it a web page like this
and you can then click through for other
interesting things this bottom line it's
kind of fun you can just survive like a
step it up right now those know what's
happening and so just to run through
this is this will do this is like this
is like want to panic apples like this
happens no panic ok and this one is this
last trip every go routines running
right now with the stack trace that how
that got started so you discover this
shows to the e so you have looking
pronoun and this one of this one I'm not
be talking detail with this talk about
it thread create will show you the all
of them stack traces we've got you to
creating an operating system thread so
if your app somebody creates a whole
load all those threads cuz you doing
something weird and that can be very
useful to find out there should be a few
more threads there are you know what if
you set get max box to write this does
that many plus a few tell ones if you we
have seen this be like in 500,000 that's
funny cuz with your community and the
block the one is if you're if you're not
doing doing synchronization with the
synchronization primitives and stuffs
login you can actually go in there and
he'll tell you these are the guys who
are waiting around this is this is the
vtx the way to model it so this can be
radius what its various one of the
things running and sometimes like I
what's going on you're strapped to it
assuming the Goma team that does this is
still operating so for example if you go
in click on government is you just get
is this is actually yeah this is when
the same program so this is the verity
running this all ready to run you know
and this is different stacktrace so you
can go and how to give you the counts as
well and there's no longer to show you
how many of each individual what have
been being created so that's the
standard and this is the running round
here so you can see there's four of
those top ones running and so on you can
see very quickly what a program is doing
this is this kind of useful if you
suddenly got some blow up and another
girl teens / set of type sometimes we'll
see if example some some image might get
popular something going around where and
you the underline server gets into
trouble so somebody's I would undergo a
teens explode did you go here just like
you know oh look you know total 255,000
to go routines of the same type or
running okay so let's improve my code
does there was a bit rubbish what
happened before so what I've done here
is I've changed a bit up now on the list
using this container I'm going to keep
them all of this Iran thing or situating
license I'm going to take the map around
so I can look things up but I'm Nikki to
lift keep order and I don't need the
time anymore mountains and so now
getting put become principal so get is
if it's there then we'll do this move to
front hooves use the list container
package here because the yeah it's
pretty nice things standard list
absolutely you know once you access
something I've moved to the practice ex
most recent thing has been used and when
you put something if it's full then I
delete the thing that's the mysteries of
the years i think the back of the list
and then put on the new thing at the
front so this is perhaps it'll be close
to whom i really want and now that Rani
12 seconds rather than almost two
minutes so yeah well put it I didn't
actually was profiling figured out but
it was there and when you run this thing
then you can run profiler on this now
looks a bit different now when you see
here is those two top things are
actually in the fingers loading the file
to test so that's not Rachel even after
that was a bunch of the garbage
collection stop going on so what's
happened there why is that might as well
your garbage going on and we can we can
kind of zooming down on the web view and
and you can see over there
the access to the map is there on this
site and I'm going to show you a better
strategy so all right so now I'm good
another strategy for a lot of you is not
to do allow the other tools to grab the
direction actually we do this so it's
quite interesting that you're all this
housekeeping to do there are you capture
the stuff it's really exciting that
actually if you just shoot some random
item in the head when you run out of
space actually need wrinkling and you
know that's how they disconnected Roman
armies and it works great so anyway here
so all but here's a lot the same thing
but I'm keeping this it's a ready GP
sort of like so I can get because of
course go there's no easy way to get
keys that we directly so I'm going to
keep that around and then when it comes
time to what getting something is easy
was going to get it and if I've got from
full then I'm going to choose a random
victim and delete them victim and then
this disease up anything here that just
deleting one element from Ray taking it
outside so do that to go and you can run
that and I think that's just about this
is a pretty close what's interesting is
that the number of mrs. cache misses is
same ballpark as it was using the LRU
that's kind of fun they're just shooting
random stuff extremely well and later
and now you discover is that when you do
the profiling is that may move as in car
collection and this memory moving things
has popped up the question is why is
moving memory problems if we run the
webview stubble the left is the subject
with reading the file or processing so
we can do is we can zoom in on that bit
by saying literally by typing web put
which is just an end of the function
into profiler I just get that and what
notices this men move is actually coming
from a pen slice so there I was a
pending to actually cut the slice of
those kidding me opening else is pretty
cheap so okay so that's so that's that
so to get rid of these slice operations
lessons a consent yours before but now
whoops now I am we have taken reusing
the slot Robin deleting offensive back
in a artists we use that slaughters now
because it'll be simpler and now I'm
down to ten seconds so so Delta come to
my so much boldness and get silly isn't
it but if you do zoom in on the here and
I should resume in protea all those
slots equations disappeared but now I'm
really down to your actual workers this
worth doing
so you could use these tools pretty
pretty well for understanding things and
I'm going to release but there's the
blocking of the ground these primitives
and onerous threads for you sir 57
trouble on line of code and we're
looking at those two particular things
ok I'm going to take it pause there I
have a whole other daughter you do about
every recycling but I'm is and also do
you like questions now profile yes
yes we'll catch to whenever yes surely
it was numbers addresses and ports for
example
I assumed there is about he never done
it all right you have to tell that
different answer but yeah I mean it just
calls xtp door handle all right so yes I
would imagine you know Peter just get in
front yeah I just got it call us and
deserve
right
yeah yeah so that's the last time i
looked at the profiler it's pretty good
but my my aunt's were never cpu-bound so
I didn't really care about cpu time did
you have any tricks about doing like
real time cuz I'm good supports
real-time samples cpu cycle right so yes
so it's sampling something ok you go so
you're right and we we will be somewhat
we're using it so we are sometimes CPU
bound for specific tasks but we also
carry off about the latency of the
individual requests right the way
through and there are a couple of things
you can do what is you just use the time
functions of your own theme there's also
a project called nitro didn't use my
true what it allows you to do is and he
or commence profiler allows you could
check points into your code you can find
out which segments of the cobra taking
the most like so keys so the existing
various learning opportunities sorry sir
liam is that little better all right let
me hold this thing is and so nitro will
allow you to actually put these yeah if
you know what the flow waves through the
code and actually in
the compression thing that I worked on
read about the whole thing which
measures the critical parts we know
where time goes alright next question
that this guy gets real wax like oh yeah
this one game oh yeah so to the first
first question is that yes that's right
as the / thurs the deeper / cough / blog
or we get it from being the with Nash
packages developer file so that doesn't
apply to life insurance no it's not fair
it's not me it really is routing are
they going to say for some rechecks more
grass again what's the performance
impact of loading the debug the debug
info on writing processes everything it
takes a lot
get the stack traces for all so yeah we
don't actually run it on all the time
absolutely we load it but we don't
enable it so what we've actually done is
use the signal package and then we have
a whole bunch of signal or the other we
look at CU 2 3 by that where we will say
right now start the CPU profiler and so
we can do it's allergies that when we
get into trouble but we have not seen an
issue with having the runtime people
package reference but we have signals
that tell you on and off okay and if you
list of your routines do you do that
integral
and
I don't think I've ever done that and
then I've ever done introduction
introduction again is to guarantee
discuss is panicked so and actually
usually we have so many go routines that
actually written tools for interpreting
those because we will have half a
million guarantees running its gonna get
stepped outside 35-6 three was running
for all right i think i will not do not
after our talk about memory recycling
the angry ones that talk about having do
it another time yes we're sites in the
world yeah yep sorry that's perfect yeah
i'll include the top secret talk here
about exciting memory brothers anything
else
all right thank you much